hello everyone and welcome to today
cast better safe than sorry safety and
maintenance for bench top centrifuges
presented by Nicole Selig Mueller an
application specialist sample handling
at Eppendorf AG I'm Cindy Valdez of
labrys and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
eppendorf Eppendorf is a leading life
science company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sample and cell handling and
laboratories worldwide before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also you'll
notice that you will be viewing this
presentation in a slide window if you'd
like to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem good news this presentation is
educational and does offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left hand corner
and follow the process for obtaining
your credits I'd now like to introduce
our presenter Nicole Selig Muller since
2015
Nicole is responsible for applications
regarding centrifugation as well as
customer support and trainings at
Eppendorf in Hamburg previously she
worked several years of the sales
representative offering the best
solutions for molecular and cell biology
for her customers during her studies at
our W th Aachen Germany she acquired a
broad spectrum of methods in the field
of biology furthermore she earned a
strong knowledge in Medical Microbiology
during her diploma thesis in 2010 at the
Institute for Veterinary Medicine
at SU Berlin in Germany please join me
in welcoming her
Nicole Selig Mueller welcome to coal
Thank You Lizzie yes and welcome
everyone I'm really happy to see that we
are a big group of attendees today and
yeah not let's not waste time and start
with the presentation better safe than
sorry
safety and maintenance for centrifuges
well well we will have a little
structure here I will talk about some
basics about certification in yeah in
general then I will come to talk about
some safety aspects I will show you some
centrifuge or accessory damages so you
can easily recognize if you have a
problem with your equipment or not and
afterwards I will give you some
practical tips about cleaning and
maintenance of centrifuges
so yeah let's start well scientists know
that centrifuges are important tools in
the laboratory daily laboratory work but
also for those who are not working in a
laboratory environment and some futures
are a part of the daily life and surely
not everyone has something like that a
cream separator at home but most of us
do own a washing machine I think here
the sensible force helps to separate
water and clothes at the end of the
washing process and also most of us have
experienced the g-force during a run on
the chera plane or even a roller coaster
yeah centrifugal forces are even
essential to produce foods most of us
have in our kitchens like olive oil or
honey and she harvest the honey for
example the beekeeper removes the frame
that has the honey comes from the hives
and places it up right into the honey
separator where the sensible force
we'll pull the honey from the cops okay
now that we know we all have centrifuges
let's put first things first
um which forces our reach-in centrifuges
to understand the importance of the safe
handling we will use our Eppendorf
centrifuge 5810 are as an example the
swing-out rotor s4 104 enables up to
3000 146 g loading forceful 750 ml
bottles into the buckets means that the
load per bucket is 1 around 1 kg so 1500
grams to 1050 grams sorry so 4 pound 2
kg in total 4 point 2 kgs fun as 3146 g
equates 13,200 13 Newton which equates
1347 kg the average weight of a
middle-class car so yeah quite
impressive we see that due to the
acceleration up to 3,000 146 G the
weight of the samples just increased
rapidly and therefore it is necessary to
pay attention to you safe working
practice when it comes to segregation so
this example here only shows the forces
during an average run and a Swing Out
rotor which is quite slow in comparison
to u6 and the rotors or even
floor-standing
and ultra centrifuges well now that
we've talked about the forces that can
be reached in centrifuges let's see what
can happen in the worst case this
picture shows the destroyed
ultracentrifuge at the Purdue University
in Indiana and yes surely this is an
incident which will not happen this way
was the normal bench top centrifuge due
to several reasons I will explain in a
bit but the possibility of the rotor
crashes all
given when the centrifuge is operated in
an incorrect way leading to the failure
of the rotor and possibly the centrifuge
as well and even if the environment is
not harmed like in the picture your
samples and your instrument will be Susy
will be so would you be so nice to send
out the link for the video because I
have prepared a little video where you
can see an actual crash test for a
centrifuge because the question is how
can we feel safe while spinning samples
well all benches and futures must
fulfill several guidelines to gain the C
so-called C II certificate and one of
them is a guideline en6 101 Oh - OH - oh
really you don't have to remember that
anyway but crash resistant construction
of the chamber so the crash resistance
of the chamber must be proved by a rotor
crash test which you can see in the
video and you must test the rotor
crashes enthused and the test is passed
at the centrifuge stays intact so
nothing getting out or causing local
buckling or anything and additionally
the centrifuge must not move more than
30 centimeters in each direction during
the crash this is why there's this line
around the centrifuge and this is also
the reason why every manufacturer
suggests to keep about 30 centimeters
free space to all sides of the
centrifuge and yes because of the
exhaust air needs to flow freely and
yeah if you're interested you can take a
look in this video and see how this
crash test takes place so talking about
some more basic information let's talk
about parameters especially rpm versus
RCS many protocols this is still usual
to use rpms or revolutions per minute in
contrast to RC F which is the
seneschal forth to describe the speed
but RTM specifies the number of
rotations around the fixed axis in 1
minute without taking the radius so the
distance from the center of the rotor to
the exterior most exterior point of the
rotor and this distinction between rpm
and RCS is important because two rotors
with different diameters running at the
same rotational speed so rpm will
without the different g-forces and we
will see this in a little example here
I'm comparing the mini spin class and
the centrifuge 54:27 are we see that
both centre stages are running at the
same speed which is 14 14 thousand rpm
but looking at the ready we see that the
radius of the rotor of the mini spin is
only 6 centimeters whereas the radius of
the rotor in the 5427 RS 10 point 1
centimeter and using this tiny little
basic formula you don't have to use that
because we will come later on to a point
where you can see it's quite easy to get
to the RCS of the only a bargain and yes
we use this formula we will see that in
the minister class the same rpm with us
in 13150 G where us was a bigger radius
or a bigger rotor the same rpm leads to
22,000 132 G which is quite a bit of a
difference and yeah this means that a
protocol which only gives the RPM value
needs to specify which centrifuge and
rotor was used and otherwise without are
not comparable because different rotors
can lead to different editing results
yes that was all about the basics let's
get a bit deeper and she
safety aspects adaptors
I think everyone especially using the
bigger bench of centrifuges is quite
familiar with adapters but why do I need
them well benchtop centrifuges can
accommodate a wide range of vessels
starting from very small volumes like
0.2 up to 2 ml tubes which are
preferential dominant in small
mentorship centrifuges to blood
collection tubes or HPLC and cry cry of
wild round bottom tube conical tube
whatever you can think of and yeah even
bigger volumes like bigger conical tubes
or even 1000 ml bottles can be spun
nowadays in many shops Center futures
and to accommodate all these different
vessels look at the time the doctors are
needed they offer the flexibility to
spin a wide range of tubes in just one
or a two different rotors and the
adapter concept means that there are
different adapter available in the
market adapters can be made of one piece
the so called mono block adapters as
well as modular adapters which can be
divided into two or more parts adjusting
to the vessel length and there are
different adapters also available
supporting the vessel bottom shade the
conical skirted all flat bottom shape as
you can see in the picture here we do
have an example for the modular system
you can see that at least 2/3 of the
tube should be supported so if you're
using modular system adapters please do
not just support the vessel bottom
because this can lead to you tube
breakage and we do also have adapters or
the manufacturer of your used vessel has
adapters supporting
the bottom shape of your vessels
especially for larger clinical vessels
like 200 250 ml conical vessels and the
manufacturer usually provides the so
called cushon for their bottles so you
can spin them in your centrifuge and if
you not sure actually which adapter
would be the best fit for your vessel
because I am quite sure that sometimes
is not an easy job to find the perfect
one and just contact your centrifuge
manufacturer I think they will be happy
to help so we have been talking about
radius just the few slides before the
question is why should I set the radius
actually and as explained earlier the
radius is important for the correct
definition of the g-force using adapters
can lead to a change in the radius
especially when you're using adapters
which are shortening the radius so in
the picture here you can see a radius
one where the vessel is at the bottom so
at the most exterior point of the rotor
but when you use a adapter like here
where the the vessels in green are not
at the most exterior point of the rotor
the radius will change and in this case
it is recommended to set the correct
radius and most centrifuges will offer
this function in their menu to make sure
that the samples will be spun at the
desired t force
yeah and it's not only about adapters
it's also about the correct rotor
loading so even without vessels there
are still some things to think about
when loading your centrifuge we do have
four examples here where the rotor is
loaded completely wrong and quite sure
that nobody would ever do this this way
but I just wanted to point out
yeah more drastic way to what what can
be done wrong so as you can see here it
should be equally loaded and especially
with swing-out routers it's necessary
that all rotor arms are loaded and for
the micro centrifuges you can see an
example here how you wrote the Eppendorf
tube correctly in your rotor or how to
load a swing back with water for conical
tubes you can also our Eppendorf on page
find a centrifuge maintenance
poster where you have a lot of examples
actually how to load your water in
correct way so it's not that hard but
yes I just wanted to make sure that this
is also heard well looking at Swing Out
rotors there are a couple of things more
to keep in mind because as I said it's
very important that our bucket slots are
occupied with buckets during the run
because spinning a rotor cross with
empty bucket slots would lead to bended
rotor arms due to the centrifugal forces
and also you should make sure that feed
buckets swing out smoothly via a manual
swing out test as you can see here in
the picture um because yeah there you
can see if your tube fits and it doesn't
touch the rotor quad and also if it
doesn't swing out properly it is
probably time to groove as you apply
grease and the groove and the pivot so
yeah these are just some tiny things to
consider when using Swing Out rockers
also it's necessary to have the balance
point in the middle of the bucket yeah
what does that mean we do have a swing
out Rogers for plates here in the
picture and if you spin play
you should always keep in mind to fill
the plates only two-thirds of the total
volume so not the total volume of the
plate but the well and for a proper
swing out when they're loaded lengthwise
so as you can see if they would swing
out like this when the rotor is in the
middle the heavier part would be on the
outside where the well wells are loaded
and you should make sure that it's done
correct correctly because the balance
point is also something you should keep
in mind that you prevent your plates and
backwards swinging out in the wrong
direction actually it's not working with
place but also with the swing up rotor
there are difference this year and you
can see here buckets loaded with cubes
and the as you can see the pivots are
not loaded equally because the tubes are
always also all of the tubes sorry put
in two on one side so that means one of
it is carrying all the weight and it's
important to load them equally because
this reduces vibrations and noise and
stress for the San Pedro true and motor
as you can see here and this example or
pivots are loaded equally and the weight
is yeah balanced quite well between the
two yeah rata load also something which
should be considered because um rotors
are yeah looking at their physics there
is a point where things can get too
heavy because we have learned in the
second slide and during turn is during
the centrifugation run and things can
get quite heavy and the maximum weight
loading weight is usually printed on the
rotor and this includes the bucket weigh
the adapter weight and the weight of
slush and simple here we can see we have
a maximum loading weight of four times
so for every
bucket and 1.1 kg it's usually printed
on the rotor and also buckets can have a
weight classes sometimes dedicated with
a number sometimes they're indicated
with just a letter but usually they have
weight classes and these must be
accumulated on opposite positions so we
have an equal weight on each side of the
rotor yep so we're halfway through let's
have a look at some centrifuge damages
or not
centrifuge damages it's more damages of
the equipment so you can maybe learn a
little bit about when to talk to you in
service engineer or just to yeah replace
your equipment talking about rotor lids
we can have plastic bottle lids for
examples and as you can see here in the
picture they can have scratches and then
they need to be replaced because they
can break during the run and to prevent
scratch rotor lids you should ensure
that they fit safely on the rotor lid
before the run because these scratches
usually develop when the rattle it is
not fixed completely in minutes getting
loose during the run and then yeah it
just flies somewhere and yeah it's not
quite good some Rogers do have
windshields as you can see here in the
picture this windshield is just further
reduce to reduce noise and to protect
your samples a little bit they can get
damaged as well if they fall down and if
your if they bang against surfaces or
anything and we would recommend to
replace them as well when they're bent
or something because they can cause
vibrations during the
and this can cause midterm damages of
the drive in the end and I don't think
anyone wants that so this is about what
a lid looking at the routers themselves
hmm what can I have light scratches on
the rotor surface as you can see here
yeah this is another direct reason to
get rid of your rotor immediately you
should continue to monitor your rotor to
detect corrosion because these scratches
meaning that the protecting elevated
surface or pure water is gone and that
there are yeah places where a corrosion
could grow and to prevent scratches on
your rotor surface try to avoid banging
and dropping off the rotors and
especially never use metallic cleaning
tools I will show you later on suited
cleaning tools for your equipment and we
can also have scratches inside of the
rotor lid after cleaning for example as
you can see here this is the inside of a
aluminum rotor lid if you use metallic
cleaning tools this can be the result
and yeah you should check them you
should continue monitoring and all use a
soft cloth for cleaning of your rotor
lids and your workplace as well and we
can have damages of the rotor curl so if
you turn your rotor upside down you can
see the rotor cone this is usually the
part where it sits on the motor shaft
and sometimes if you're in a hurry or
you don't really yeah
pay attention then
it can be the case that this part this
part hits the motor shaft leading to
these little damages yeah
the area should be checked for gorges
and yeah if necessary should take the
rotor out of service because this is an
important area here too even though it's
quite underestimated most of the time
and you should really pay attention to
always assembly and remove the rotor
straight from the top and to avoid any
angle or a bending or something like
that and then everything should be fine
well talking about rotor cones the
opposite part the motor shaft and the
centrifuge where the rotor combs sit on
and this can be bent because of the same
reason if you don't set up and lift the
rotor in and straight up motion or if
there are angles or whatever then yeah
the motor shaft can bend and this is the
where you should definitely send
yourself future service and then just
the shaft can be exchanged also you
should always make sure that your
samples are balanced symmetrically
because due to imbalances this part of
the centrifuge can get damaged in
midterm run yeah we can have gorgeous on
the outer rotor surface which is like
the really deep scratch you can see it
in a picture here this is the reason to
replace the rotor because it's a very
deep scratch and this can actually in
the worst case lead to a rotor crash and
yeah I would avoid to spin the rotor in
that state we can also have a damaged
thread of the fixed angle what was it so
this is the again the downside of a
aluminum water lid and when you screw
this lid on to the rotor and it's a bit
hard sometimes
or temp - yeah push it or to use a
higher force to just properly screw the
lid on the rotor but this can result in
these little damages and then I would
recommend to replace the lid and always
use the same lid for the same rotor
usually rotors come with a lid and yeah
clean and for example lubricate these
threads regularly I will talk about
lubrication a little bit later
oopsie there's already a mark let's see
what are okay um so we have bucket
grooves
Swing Out buckets this is a plate bucket
here also when when you place these
buckets on the pivot you should pay a
bit of attention to not bang them
because then this can also lead to
damage and I would then suggest you
replace the buckets usually you should
replace them pairwise due to the weight
class and we can also have damages not
only on fixed angle rotors but also a
rotor cross of the swing out rotor as
you can see here and this is also
something where I would recommend to
continually monitor your rotor cross and
if these damages get bigger or deeper or
whatever I would recommend to replace
the rotor and how to prevent damages
like this is easy just as I suggested a
couple of slides before if you're using
new tube we're not sure if the tube is
not too long for the rotor just perform
a manual Swing Out test and before
spinning it and then you can this way
you can make sure that the tubes won't
touch the rotor cross during the spin
and you don't have to do this every time
if you use the same
chips forever and ever but if you switch
and I would recommend the manual
swing-out test yeah a lot of people in
the lab are working with DNA or RNA
extraction kits and from them we can see
that there are sometimes assad
encrustations which can lead to
corrosion so here's a picture of thought
Krystal Deborah's on a rotary surface
from my side I was working and
laboratory a lock with the extraction
kids and usually rotors look like this
this is something which can be prevented
by just regular cleaning especially when
it's you brakes as you can see in the
second picture this is a lot of residue
from salt and don't let this dry and
stay on the rotor just take a moist
cloth and wipe it away this will prolong
the what a lifetime we can have the same
in buckets as well here is the example
of a Swing Out bucket where customers
were working with salt buffers and yeah
as you can see there were were like two
breakages and the residue was left in
the bucket and over the time the salt
crystals can eat into the material
mm-hmm which can if you keep these
buckets for a long time yeah lead to a
weak spot in the bottom of the bucket so
I would recommend to clean afterwards
and if you see buckets like those
replace them because yeah you risk
corrosion and you risk a
rotor crash in the West case we can have
also advanced corrosion if you jump
clean and you don't care you might see
something like this it's like a
see-through rotor
saw hole and it's a complete hole in the
rotor which is actually not funny
because and these spots can result in a
rotor crash that's what I meant with the
worst case if you see rather like this
please get rid of it and yeah because
there is nothing left to clean or to
repair or anything it's just risk for
your equipment ok so these were some
examples for some cents each or a
centrifuge equipment damages I know they
they look quite dramatically and not
every lab I think will have this problem
they were just yeah examples of how
equipment can look like and what should
be considered and what you can do is
something we will talk about now in
cleaning and maintenance part so the
manual cleaning procedure for a
centrifuge is as follows you shipped
clean and dry centrifuge chamber after
it run this would be the perfect world
mm-hmm
you can do it at the end of the day and
especially the lid should be remaining
open overnight you let for example if
you're working at for increase there
will be a little ice buildup in the
center fuge and so when you leave the
lid open overnight this can dry and just
evaporate yeah you can use a soft cloth
to clean the centrifuge housing the
chamber also the rotor shaft worker and
resolute and caps so no metallic
cleaning tools just a soft soft
Moyes class you can use neutral cleaning
agents like soap or if you want to
disinfect ethanol and yeah if you have
thought incrustation as we have seen a
couple of slides before maybe a tube
broke or something then we clean the
chamber and the router immediately after
the run just water a neutral agent
neutral cleaning agent and the soft
brush you can also fill the bar holes
with water because usually the most of
the content of the tube will be in the
bore holes and you can fill them with
water to clean them but you should not
dip the router completely in water
because the water has openings like from
the like as it have seen with the rotor
CONUS and water can get into the rotor
and it might remain in the openings and
this can then if the water stays still
in there and each you little imbalance
problem so please do not dip the rotor
in water and yeah you can dry it with a
soft cloth as you can see in the
pictures it's not a lot of work it just
should be done regularly if we have the
tube breakage and the risk of
contamination because we're working with
infectious samples for example and there
are a couple of more things you should
consider you should always wear a lab
coat I know everyone is doing that in
the laboratory gloves and protective
goggles during the continental con
decontamination process as you can see
here is an example let's say this is
blood and it was filled in your
centrifuge and you've been working with
glass tubes if you have broken glass
pieces and retrieves the bigger pieces
with forceps and small and powder shards
can
removed with a damp lint-free cloth yeah
you can absorb the spilled sample with
God's or just a paper towel and then
feel the infectious material in a
biohazard bag so you can just dispose it
afterwards then what the contaminated
part with distilled water or you can use
soft cloth or a literally lint-free
cloth
yeah the contaminated rotor can be
removed from the centrifuge then and
then you can wipe the parts you cannot
really reach if the water is still in
the centrifuge and then you can clean
the rotor and everything and wipe it
with a cleaning agent or for example 70%
ethanol and if necessary you can also
autoclave your equipment at usually 121
degrees for 20 minutes so yeah I've been
I have promised I will tarry something
about cleaning tools that can be used so
allowed our plastic scrub pads if you
have stubborn contamination or a stiff
brush with an bristles and very
important and nonmetallic tip so you can
have these brushes with just plastic
tips you can use that for the bottles
for example and you shouldn't use steel
wool you shouldn't use abrasive abrasive
cleaning agents yeah brushes with
metallic parts or even completely made
of metal and other abrasive books going
back to that sorry
abrasive just keep in mind maybe you
think of your car and then think of what
I use that to clean my car because it's
quite
and then yeah I think it's quite clear
what you use and what not okay
dishwasher you're going to put your car
in the dishwasher won't you and so
please don't put your Watchers in a
dishwasher because this will be the
result because the sauce used in a
dishwasher can remove the elevated
surface of the rotors and this can lead
to corrosion and then the corrosion can
grow it can cause fatigue or holes even
and then a continued operation is
dangerous so I'm sorry but no dishwasher
for rotors not for buckets and not for a
lot of crosses but I'm totally fine with
putting adapters and the dishwasher so
maybe some little relief okay
disinfection wish them talking about
cleaning now let's talk about this
infection especially when you work with
infectious or simples like bacteria
whatever you probably would like to
disinfect your equipment your centrifuge
but there are some things to consider
please do not use UV betta or gamma
radiation or any other high-end ready
high-energy radiation source for the
disinfection because this can harm your
equipment also I don't recommend gaseous
disinfection of the machine of your
centrifuge itself by aerosol so like
hydrogen percocet or similar agents the
equipment is fine so you can disinfect
the rotor or buckets or even the rotor
crosses where scheduled is hydrogen
peroxide but please not the Machine and
yeah we do offer a use manual there are
a lot of instructions in there as well a
few
have questions you can always ask your
distributor if your disinfectant is
suitable so if you're probably working
with a special disinfectant just let us
know and we can say yes we've tested
that with the material and everything's
fine or we can even recommend whatever
you can find a example here so there's
quite a lot of disinfectants we have
tested them with different materials of
our Eppendorf equipment and you can see
this is an overview what you can use and
this can also be found in our home page
we have a complete white paper about it
it's called white paper 14 and yeah it's
also easy to download on our Eppendorf
centrifuge section yeah last but not
least autoclaving also yeah necessary to
sterilize your equipment the rotors can
be autoclaved at as I said 121 degrees
for 20 minutes except specially
especially coated rotor crosses these
can be sterilized with gaseous hydrogen
peroxide as I said there are also
special rotors on the market which can
be autoclaved up to 135 or even 142
degrees especially for those of you
working with prions and yeah you just
should remove the lid from the rotor as
you can see in the picture just put it
next to the rotor but don't yeah let the
lid to be attached
during the autoclaving run and yeah
lubrication I promised we do have our
centrifuge grease if you were ever
wondering when ordering a rotor and
there's a little tube little white tube
coming with
this is a scented crease and you can use
it to lubricate the Roger Tsien Brazil
for example this is made of rubber and
when it gets a bit older it can get a
bit dry it's like skin as you can maybe
imagine and then just lubricate it
after cleaning you can also lubricate
the pivots of the swing out rotors and
bucket groups especially when you have
the feeling that you quite that you
balance your samples quite well but it's
still a little bit yeah a little bit of
vibration this might be the reason so
just put a little bit of grease on there
also the threads of fixed angle rotors
can be lubricated so if the rotor lid is
hard to close or jopen this can help you
can also put a little bit of rotor
grease on the rotor surface that can
also prolong the rotor lifetime
and do not duplicate the motor shaft or
the rotor Kona's so the bottom side of
the rotor because these are parts which
should be dry and you when you grease
that and there might be the risk a risk
of yeah you that the rotor is not
properly fixed on there and because of
that we don't want that to be greased
but the rest is fine as you can see here
in the examples okay so this was
everything from my side I one say thank
you for attention if you want you have
more information about centrifuges
applications whatever you can think of
we do have a new website our sample
handling website and Susy will send out
a link for you in a bit
if you want more information just pop
over there
and have a look around and yes so now
I'm open for your questions and happy to
answer some of them I think we have
quite a bit of time left so let's have a
look
Nicole thank you so much for your
informative presentation
and we will now start that live Q&A
portion of the webinar there's a
fantastic audience today just remember
if you'd like to ask a question please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button we're going to
answer as many questions as we have
possible for today
so let's get started with our first set
of questions our first audience member
would like to know Nicole after
centrifuging samples at low temperatures
like 4c or lower condensation will build
up inside the centrifuge what are your
recommendations for drying it out is
leaving it open fine or is dust a
concern no I don't think that death is a
concern here so at the end of the day I
would just recommend you so if you have
for example a little bit of ice buildup
what you can do is also like a short run
at let's say 30 degrees so just set your
centrifuge to 30 degrees do like a 10 15
minute run this will melt everything and
when you then open the centrifuge and
let everything evaporate it's a quicker
way but if you have the time to just
open your centrifuge to leave it open
overnight maybe why'd it wipe it out
before you leave the laboratory that's
fine and no justice no concerns you
don't have to worry about that all right
our next audience member would like to
know you just talked about salt and
crustaceans on rotors from DNA and RNA
kit I have such salt
does it but wiping with a moist cloth
doesn't always help the salt is too like
encrusted can we clean the rotor with a
plastic dish brush or something
equivalent yes as I said before
everything made of plastic you can also
use a little plastic brush I haven't
shown these brushes you can you probably
know them from your kitchen for example
from the dishwashing part you can just
use them to try to remove the residues
the only thing you should really keep in
mind is to not use metallic cleaning
tools but the rest is fine yes and Yuko
here's a related question how would
someone avoid leaks in those rotors or
anywhere while centrifuging Leeson
rotors I do mean probably leaks in the
vessel to use so what I recommend is to
consider there's usually a maximum and
minimum filling volume of YouTube so
chief shouldn't be filled more than 80%
because after yeah more than 80% there
there especially with swing out rotors
the liquid can touch the threat of the
of the vessel and if the tube is not
correctly closed then this can lead to
leakage or for example if the maximum
speed recommendation for YouTube usually
some yeah like conical tubes some of
them are some fusible up to 5000 others
are
usable up to 19,000 for example it's
always considered this as well if you
spend your chips at a too high speed
they might break and this is something
you can really prevent great thank you
you know we have an incredible audience
today very captivated and we have a lot
of questions coming in
here's another related question I think
we have a 500 and I'm sorry 5424
centrifuge because it was a bit dirty I
wanted to take the rotor out but it
wasn't quite possible after unscrewing
it it wouldn't come on off the shaft
should that be possible
well usually should be possible to
remove the rudder yeah sometimes if you
don't clean it for a while then the
rotor can be stuck sometimes it helps to
have like a strongman
sometimes you have to have a strong man
called service technician to remove the
rotor so I wouldn't recommend to put
like high forces on the rotor and and
and yeah try to remove it yeah when it
doesn't want to be removed maybe it's
stuck in there and so I would recommend
to ask a service technician for help
actually great thank you here's a
question from across the world what
method would you recommend for safely
measuring the RPM /r CF on a centrifuge
that does not have a tach meter window
Sakamura tackle meter window so it's
probably quite a old centrifuge well hmm
that's really hard I mean yes service
technicians they have the tools to
measure the speed while they have
special tools for that but yeah I don't
think that there is a very safe way to
to
that if you have just like in a car the
tachometer them without digits so yeah I
don't sorry I don't really see a perfect
way to perfectly measure this I mean if
you have an alternative just saying rpm
and you really want to know what is the
RC F then this is possible so you can
actually take the radius of your rotor
if you don't know the radius we should
ask your manufacturer for the radius of
your rotor and then there is for example
on the website I've just recommended the
sample handling website from Eppendorf
there's an RPM RCS calculator if you put
in there the RPM and then the radius of
your rotor it will come up with the RCS
so we cannot really control every
centrifuges spinning at the right speed
but we can definitely help you to
calculate the RCS if you only have rpm
great thank you and I think our audience
again for such an active participation
our next question comes from an audience
member saying I think bucket caps or
useful added containment when working
with infectious or hazardous materials
does Eppendorf plan to make these bucket
caps standard accessories with all
centrifuges yeah we do not only plan
this I think that's in yeah 95% of our
rotor is already the case so for example
all of our six angular rotor is coming
with a retina
mmm that means that there are arrows all
tied and we're shifting more and more
towards producing arrows all tied
throughout her lids so if you have an
older centrifuge like 54-17 for example
there are
yeah non-aerosol tideless on there but
all new machines and every centrifuge
that will be released in the future they
will all give the user the possibility
to use aerosol type caps and it's
definitely yes
great our next question is why should I
look for an automatic rotor recognition
in my centrifuge um it's a safety thing
so if you for example have personnel
like students or interns in your
laboratory and they are not quite
familiar with how to load the rotor
probably it might be the case that
someone is spinning the centrifuge with
an unbalanced rotor which can lead to a
yeah some problems if the centrifuge
doesn't shut off automatically so an
ambulance reckon automatic imbalance
recognition means that the centrifuge is
built in a way that it can detect an
imbalance and trigger a kind of
emergency shut off before there will be
damages or incidents during the run so
if the centrifuge recognizes there's an
imbalance it will shut off the run and
will break and then it will give you a
yeah a message imbalance and then yeah
you should probably properly balance
your samples again it's just to protect
you and your centrifuge as well thank
you so much there's a centrifuge need a
regular calibration no well all of our
sanity I'm just talking about
Peschel centrifuges now I cannot talk
for example for Ultra centrifuges but
they don't need calibration if you want
to and if you're working in a regulated
area then you can have the service
technician coming like once a year doing
a OQ for example but there's this this
is not necessary if you want to spin and
just to work and whatever you can use
your centrifuge as long as you want
without having someone coming over to
check it and the parameters all should
be fine
so there's no need for an S for a
regularity calibration it's not like a
car where you should go to yeah to have
it check from time to time wonderful
again thank you so much to our audience
numbers
our next question you talked about
balancing rotors but it is fine to do
mixed loading and swing bucket rotors
right and it's actually a two-part
question that's the first part like 15
milliliter conical tube across from each
other and 50 ml conical tubes across
from each other does mix loading like
this reduce the life of the rotor I hope
that made sense yeah I understand what
you mean well there are some routers
made for this so if you have 15 and for
example 50 ml mix backward loading the
only important thing is that the buckets
opposite of each other are balanced but
you can also spin with the dedicated so
not all rotors can do this but the
rotors which can do this they are marked
so we definitely tell you that
these are rotors which can do mix packet
loading and then you can spin like two
plates opposite of each other and then
like 50 ml conical tubes at the two
other places but this is fine we have
tested these rotors under these
circumstances and therefore it's
completely fine you only have to make
sure that everything opposite of each
other is balanced well great thank you
mm-hmm our next question is my lab using
the stores are marked microfuge in our
biological cabinet each day and between
different types of samples we use these
a biological cabinet with the top closed
on the microfuge with the UV still
damaged that it or is this only when it
is open when it is open the rotor
directly exposes the RV
I'm sorry buv yeah so oh yeah I think
you've been talking about the what I
said high-energy radiation like UV
better whatever
this is more due to the material so it
will be fine for the rotor but since as
you can imagine plastic for example will
age during it will age due to UV light
and so our equipment is fine with the
normal UV light it shouldn't be set up
where there is direct sunlight all the
time because this will heat up the
machine but it's more a matter of
material
and material aging when there is a
higher amount of UV light on the self
huge surface and I'm not quite sure if
we have done tests for longest powder to
disinfection UV light I think I would
need to check that and come back to you
via email because right now I cannot
speak for every centrifuge here so yeah
but I will definitely check I am quite
sure that our materials really robust
and that it should be fine for a while
but if you do this for like 10-15 years
then I am not sure what would happen to
the material in long-term run great
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions and I want to
remind the audience members that the
questions that weren't answered today
Nicole is agreed to email some of those
answers out to you so thank you again
for your participation
what does imbalance recognition mean
well imbalance recognition I think this
is um I've got a DJ ooh yeah and that is
recognition is the yes so it means the
syrup each can recognize an imbalance so
sphere rotor is not loaded properly and
you might know the case when you do this
because you're kind of in a hurry or
whatever then the Seraph you will start
shaking a little bit and if this is
getting too much the centrifuge can
recognize it and then stop the run to
kind of pull the emergency trigger
because if there would be a high
imbalance and the service future would
run and run
and the center stage can start to move
and we don't really want that and we
don't want to damage our motor shaft as
well which can happen due to imbalance -
so the imbalance recognition is there to
protect you and your centrifuge from
damages due to imminence great thank you
a last question that we're going to be
able to answer to today's live webinar
comes from New York City at Mount Sinai
School of Medicine we inherit a
refrigerate centrifuge that has a lot of
salt crystals do you have any specific
agent we can use we tried to clean we
tried cleaning with water still dirt but
the water is still dirty also if we use
a centrifuge all the time at 4°c is it
still recommended still to keep the
centrifuge open overnight yeah so it's
kind of - questioning one so firstly I'm
not crystals I would maybe try a few
only yeah only used like a cloth so try
to use like a plastic scrub brush and
then you can if you have salt crystals
like in the bottles you can fill the bar
holes with water and let them sit for a
while or if it's more on the surface of
the rotor you can take like a moist
cloth and put this cloth on the surface
and let it leave it there for a while to
kind of soak the salt crystals and get
them a bit yeah softer again and then
you can use your plastic brush to try
and scrub it away but yeah actually the
best way to is to prevent salt crystals
and residues with the regular cleaning
so the second question so second part
again of the
was a Suzy can you repeat that I think
they wanted to know if they have the
Seraph you refrigerated at 4 degrees if
they if it's okay to leave the
centrifuge open overnight yeah yeah so
well if you yeah a lot of people do this
they cooled down the centrifuge to 4
degrees in the morning leave it closed
through the whole day because then
Center teachers always ready to go and
this is something which actually
shortens the lifetime of the compressor
a little bit so I would recommend to
shut the center seat off in the evening
and let it open overnight because this
will then yeah help to prolong the
lifetime of the compressor because I
don't think anyone's working there
hopefully during the night so it's
better for the centrifuge to yeah
have like a break during the night and
when there's a little ice build up which
can be evaporate and dry overnight it's
also nice because if its moist and I see
all the time this can also lead to
corrosion long term run and so yes I
would definitely recommend to keep the
center stage open overnight and this is
the best way to to care for your
centrifuge Nicole thank you so much for
your presentation today and for helping
researchers across the world be safe I
also want to thank audience members for
their amazing participation and cool did
you want it have any closing remarks
before we close our webinar well no just
thank you for participating and yeah
hope to see you soon maybe on future
webinars
absolutely thank you again labyrinths
for making today's educational webcast
possible
I want to let audience know before we go
that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
and we hope to see you again bye-bye